There are several syntactical tricks
available to make closure expressions
super concise.
In fact, this is one of the coolest
aspects of closure expressions in Swift.
And at times,
one of the most confounding.
I want to walk you through some of these
tricks using the filter method from
the array class.
The filter method is called by
an instance of the array class.
It takes in a condition
as an argument and
returns an array that's been
filtered based on that condition.
The condition is passed in as a closure.
Here I have an array of examGrades and
I'm going to filter this array for
all the grades above 70.
We'll call those grades passingGrades.
So I call the filter method
with the object examGrades and
I pass in a closure representing
the filter condition.
The closure takes in a grade and
int, and
returns a Bool representing
whether the condition is true.
At this point, this looks a lot
like the syntax we saw for sort.
Here's the first trick.
The compiler can infer
closure expression types
based on what parameter type
a given function expects.
In this case, the compiler can infer
that the closure expression for filter.
We'll take in a parameter that matches
the type of the array being filtered.
The compiler can also infer that
this closure will return a Bool.
So here we can leave out the word Int
and we can leave out the word Bool.
And over here in the side bar, you can
see that we still get the same result.
Onto the next check.
If a closure is a single
expression like this one.
It can be inferred that the result of
that expression should be returned, so
we can remove the word return.
And again, over here in the sidebar,
you can see that our filter still works.
And now for the trick that's been known
to make some code reader's head spin.
Shorthand argument names.
Swift provides default argument
names for closure expressions.
So instead of specifying
a first argument,
the first argument is known as $0.
The second argument is known as $1 and
so on.
So here for example, we don't have
to give this argument a name.
We don't have to use the name grade,
we can just use the default name for
the first argument, $0.
And since we're not giving
grade a name anymore,
we can omit it here as well
along with the word in.
Let's see all those
shortcuts one more time.
We'll go back to the alphabeticalSoup
example from your quiz.
The closure expression parameter and
return types can be inferred.
So we can take out String, String and
Bool, along with the arrow of course.
This is a single expression closure, so
it can be inferred that it returns
the result of the single expression.
So we can leave out return, and
we can use shorthand argument names for
soup1 and soup2.
And we're left with a statement
that truly is amazingly concise.